teame
日本の歯医者
第2章
白いカウンターの向こう側でマスクをした清楚なお姉さんが静かに書類の整理をして
いる
マスクで顔が見えないので僕は自然と他のところに視線を向ける
ピンク色の神事のピアスどことなくロシアの体操選手思い出させる茶髪がポニーテール
細長い州の爪
それに純粋
さを思わせると同時になんだかエロい雰囲気を醸し出す看護婦の制服青いスリッパん
まで一通り眺めてから僕はマスクの方に視線を戻した
それとどんな口元を隠しているのか分からない白い布は想像力と男性ホルモンを刺激し
て革製ソファに座っている僕をしろと av 監督にしてしまった
今日
どうされましたか歯の痛みが
それから
心の痛みがまあそれはいけませんで特別な治療をしなければ僕の部屋にお入りになって
少々お待ちくださいすぐにあの道具を持ってまいりますので
コスプレ妄想を膨らませているうちにカウンターの後ろのドアからもう一人ほっそいし
たおねーさんが出てきてそっと受付の椅子に腰を下ろした
そう
の3点
僕は脚を組んだふーん
もし映画 dirty dancing のヒロインが20年ほど朝昼晩マックを食べ
ていたらそんな感じのぽっちゃりしたくるくるヘアの中年オンナがくちゃくちゃがもう
か見ながら新聞のクロスワードやっている
時々鉛筆の消しゴムを唇に当てながら
ん
qs
と呟く大きな金色の風ピアリングをして
バーバラという白いネームプレートを胸につけているそれから部屋の空気がムシムシし
ているっていうのに
安っぽい気がをのマフラーをしているオシャレのつもりなんだろうがむしろ車にはね
られて死んだタヌキを適当に水で洗って首に巻いたように見える
僕はホコリまみれのスノー苦労と90年代に流行ったおもちゃ beanie baby
の2をのせたカウンターの前で立ち止まりバーバラばあさんふと顔を上げた
うんいいで始まる大きな動物知らない彼女はクォーターパウンドの匂いがする
me